speaking of the Colts and their owner
Jim Irsay who would desperately love to
keep the combine in Indianapolis other
topics that came up when he met with the
media on Sunday the quarterback position
now he was smart to not mention any
quarterbacks currently under contract
with other teams all of that tampering
will happen away from microphones and
cameras this week in Indianapolis but he
made it clear that all options are on
the table for the Colts quarterback
position in 2020 the got jacobi percent
under contract they got Brian Hoyer
under contract for sets contract isn't
so significant that they couldn't go out
and sign someone to a close to market
value deal if that's what they want to
do but Peter this is the year hey if
you're ever going to be looking for a
quarterback in free agency this is the
year to do it and think of how the Colts
have lucked out 1998 peyton manning here
comes a generational talent they get him
with the first overall pick 2012 another
generational talent although he didn't
choose to play for a full generation
Andrew Luck and now in their first draft
after luck retires in their first off
season after luck retires they need a
quarterback and there's all these
options available in free agency I mean
three straight times now when they've
been in urgent need for a quarterback
they've had a path to getting one this
one though is going to be more of a
challenge because you got to pick the
right one and you better hope that he
wants you and you better hope it all
works out see I don't think this is the
time for them to take a generational
quarter bang I think because when you
pick where are they picking 12 no no
free agency they can address their
quarterback urgency it may be a guy
who's if they get Ryan Tannehill he
could be there for another 7 or 10 years
no question but I think what they're
more likely to do I I cannot believe the
Tennessee Titans would not resign Ryan
Tannehill I just I don't know why I
can't believe it
Mike he he had 117 rating he played 15
games this was not a cameo appearance he
basically saved their season but but
they would we'll talk about that another
time my whole thing is for the
Indianapolis Colts at this moment at
this time the guy for them is Philip
Rivers I believe there
going to pursue Philip Rivers try to
sign Philip Rivers and I believe Philip
Rivers will want the Indianapolis Colts
for two big reasons number one their
quarterback away from winning you know
if the Tennessee Titans one as big as
the Titans did this year there is no
reason why the Indianapolis Colts can't
be that team and that division next year
and number two Philip Rivers wants he
wants to be a short-termer he wants to
be one or two years so that is perfect
for the Colts because by the end of next
year by the end of 2020 they're gonna
know if Jacoby Brissette has longer than
just a cameo future with them and then
they're gonna be able to head into 2021
Draft and know we have to get a
quarterback let me say something about
Tannehill I think the hesitation comes
from a dynamic we've seen play out with
other players in the past you give a guy
a big contract and things may change and
with Tannehill there were injury issues
earlier in his career this year it was
nothing to lose come out play hard he
became the starter after they they
struggled to a two and four start and
Mariota got benched and and it all
worked the planets lined up the question
is do the planets stay lined up for Ryan
Tannehill or do they go back into
disarray like they were the first
several years of his career and if
you're gonna make a 25 to 30 million
dollar a year or more investment in Ryan
Tannehill you're taking a hell of a risk
and for the Colts look that's why I
think Phillip Rivers does make sense it
is very short-term he has said himself
he wants to play a maximum of two more
years they do need to have a plan beyond
that but at least they have a plan for
now that he's better potentially than
jacobi percent although Frank Reich and
they may may be he's just being nice and
he's supporting his guy at the end of
the season Frank Reich made it clear
he's all-in with Brissette Chris Ballard
the GM of the team has been more
equivocal than that but it's it's it's
clear that they're at least going to see
what's out there in this crazy game of
musical chairs where I still don't know
are there more butts than seats or more
seats than butts when the music stops
well I mean we can talk about Jameis
Winston for that I mean I had a note in
my column this week that you know I
would just love to see Jameis wins
and back up Ben Roethlisberger this year
Jameis Winston I doubt sincerely is
gonna start for somebody on opening day
in 2020
I shouldn't say doubt sincerely I doubt
but and and that's why I would like to
see a guy like Jameis Winston not
necessarily look in 2020 where can I go
and play the most games in 2020 where
can I go and it'd be the best situation
wouldn't you love to be the heir to Ben
Roethlisberger and to play for Mike
Tomlin to play with that defense how
great a situation would that be for a
quarterback and he gets to learn the
Steelers culture and hopefully he gets
to turn the ball over less you know and
again there's no guarantee on that but
that's why Mike when you say are there
more butts for seats or seats or butts I
believe there are many more butts than
there are seats available and that's why
a guy like Jameis Winston who I'm sure
is thinking well I'll be starting
somewhere next year he's gonna have to
think again once this process starts if
as I assume the Bucs go after either
Teddy Bridgewater or somebody else
unbelievable to think that a guy who had
5,000 109 passing yards is not gonna be
starting in 2020 we've already been down
that rabbit hole a couple of weeks ago
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports